hey the comments now have gotten so
[ __ ] bad
that i'm introducing a new segment on
this channel called
fan common of the day it's fan comment
of the day
with your host felix k jericho
burke hedrewberg kajurel bergdy
cargill bear kedzelberg that's right
i'm so desperate for praise and
validation
and just overall positive feedback that
i now
am going to read out every single
episode a nice comment
from yesterday's video that's right
finally
there will be some positivity in this
community let's see what today's fan
comment is
it's from mary jane chikua
how about delete your ch god [ __ ]
damn it god i can't [ __ ] i can't do
anything
yeah how about you delete your account i
can probably get you deleted by the way
youtube you better do something about
this merry [ __ ] jane
anyhow who's excited for e3 raise your
hand
something this makes me feel good that's
another one on
no okay we'll race your hand anyway as
long as moses held up his hands
his army would win the battle a3 is
coming up this year it's about a week
away
i've been asked to be on e3 many times
before
and i always say no because of one and
one simple goddamn reason
i don't want to be part of the cringe
compilations e3 has so many cringy
moments
it's goddamn beautiful uh from
from tech difficulties
it will happen i promise
i'm fine
too awkward interactions some people try
teleporting some people try
stationary what do you guys go with are
you reciting the questions
sorry are you recycling the questions to
whatever the [ __ ] this is
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
i will never step near that [ __ ] because
i know
i'm gonna end up there right [ __ ]
away as soon as someone puts puts a mic
in their camera in front of me
you know i'm gonna [ __ ] up how would i
ever be cringy in public that has never
happened before
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay that was one time that was one
goddamn time and it's never happened
after that
there you go yes
that was awful what whatever whatever
whatever
i'm getting sweaty now
we're gonna review some of my favorite
moments from e3
to get excited about e3 2017.
let's go and we're certainly not
interested in conventional thinking
this is an old classic it's a no it's
really one of it's a fantastic
conference
it's from 2006 it's sony's e3 presence
and we're certainly not interested in
conventional thinking uh
genji two is an ashen game which is
based on japanese history
hey it's me different clothing
oh well let me tell you the video did
not get corrupted
and now i have to reshoot it that did
not happen
so they announced this game called genji
2. genji 2
is an action game which is based on
japanese history
that sounds pretty cool a game based on
sounds like a game i want to play the um
stages of the game will also be based on
famous battles which took actually took
place in ancient japan
actual battles in that happen in japan's
history
that's a really cool concept because i
know japan has like a lot of
old old history and a lot of different
stuff happen that's really cool
so here's this giant enemy crab
gets me every [ __ ] time
it's a historical game based on japan's
history
so here's this giant enemy crab
oh it's so good why of course a giant
enemy crab just as i remember
it back in the good old days thank god i
voted trump
or else there might be more of them my
man again
shiggy is at it she guru miyamoto
announcing his new game his zelda
skyward
at e3 but it hurts me every time he had
some difficulties
i'll just take this one out with my
sword there we go
it hurts
to see my man chicken like this
why are we still here
just to suffer technical difficulties
during e3 it's always going to happen
you just can't avoid it but being a
[ __ ]
that's avoidable jamie kennedy
uh comedian i don't know who he was but
he decided to show up drunk
during the activision's e3 press
conference
it's
[Music]
how's everybody doing jamie kennedy
comedian this is exciting we're at e3
and i just want to say this place is the
only place that makes the guys at
comic-con
look like ocean's 13.
take a minute come on that was
i uh video games um
they've been uh what are my jokes
oh my god this guy is literally me
making videos
oh capture or getting on video
[ __ ] crazy play it on the game
especially with the new consoles it just
looks
it looks real okay so if you're grabbing
you're the way you grab your trick yeah
but for real you know like your trick
and then yeah i grabbed the tree yeah
and then you they could grab their trick
and we hope one day jamie you get to
grab a trick hey i grabbed it
every friday but i'm sorry i like tony
hawk's response like
yeah you yeah trick and then yeah i
grabbed the tree yeah yeah
it's like he's talking to a
three-year-old this [ __ ] guy
running through the crowd
all right please hire that man for 2017
please tell me that he's coming for next
year
i love that man another beautiful one
is the peggle 2 announcement you think
the conference is over
but out comes this guy
just pure cringe this guy oozes cringe
i don't know what it is i mean that was
amazing thanks so much
i'd say i was speechless but i have one
more thing to announce
just look at his [ __ ] face i mean
what is with these people that are
cringy they all look the same
look he looks exactly like the dust off
gamer guy
he's like the same [ __ ] person say i
was speechless
but i have one more thing to announce
coming and he announces this
[ __ ] oh my god jesus christ can you
imagine
[Music]
a valve valve duster e3 conference
it's all over they they announced
another left for dead
they announced some new tournaments for
dota they talked a little bit about
overwatch
it's all over the room is quiet
oozing for something else outcome
gabe newell naked dipped in baby oil
half-life 3.
that's my dream that's my e3 dream what
is yours
all right enough [ __ ] i saved the
best for last konami
2010 press conference there's so much to
say about this this deserves this whole
one hour breakdown but i'm gonna
summarize the best bits for you guys
first of all the [ __ ] intro it goes
quiet
for a good about two minutes
some guy goes upstage
can we roll the trailer please they
asked to roll the trailer
oh wow what a great trailer
they play some music
they cut it out sorry i don't know i'm
just describing but it's so [ __ ]
bizarre
and then this [ __ ] guy just comes out
hi and this guy's legendary
oh dude this [ __ ] dude where do i
where do i begin with this guy he's he's
uh
he's hyping his new game 99 nights
to one million troops one
million troops
wow wow the audience one
million audiences are really one million
trips
wow one man love you guys
there's one quote that is absolutely the
best
this is not the original hack and slash
anymore it's not original this is
not funny i love him
oh man oh man if you just uh you know
continue
to press the same button like x axis and
y
y y and x x and y y again you'll be
sucked
[Laughter]
i love him so much press the the same
button like
x axis and y y y and x x and y y
again you'll be sucked if you just press
the x
x y y x x x y you'll be
sucked i can't wait for e3 2017
but not for the games the games are
great and all
but this [ __ ]
is priceless anyway i hope you guys
enjoyed this video leave a like if you
did
let me know if you're excited by e3 you
can uh lower your hand now
and as always stay awesome bros i mean
sorry
uh sister fist
so here's this giant enemy crab extreme